hello Internet Nate Livingston here
let's talk about Emily 14 the show on
our brand new game mode community
challenges we've built a tool that
allows you to create custom challenges
and share them with the community the
result will be a huge variety of
bite-size game sessions that test your
abilities in a competitive social
setting the best way to understand
community challenges to play a challenge
so let's quickly run through it the
Browse challenges screen features a list
that constantly updates a trending
content filters allow us to narrow our
search based on our preferences
challenges have icons that give us info
about them this one is repeating meaning
will be attempting the same game
situation over and over it also has an
auto hit dialed in which tells us we're
on defense and will always see the exact
same hit to succeed we must rob three
home runs in 10 attempts for the
purposes of time we've quickly cut
together my successes and my friend
Ramon's failures no thanks to Ramon we
have succeeded at this challenge do we
recommend this challenge oh yeah these
votes factor into what challenges are
featured in the trending list we were
browsing earlier yay we won stuff we're
also on the leaderboard each challenge
has its own dedicated leaderboard with a
Stubbs bonus going to the top score each
week this creates a very personal sense
of competition when jockeying for
leaderboard spots
when it comes to content the fact is
many of you are just as capable at
creating compelling stuff as we are we
just needed to deliver the tools with
community challenges you and the devs we
use the same in-game tools to create
content so let's go check out how simple
it was to make the home run robbing
challenge we just attempted for this
challenge we're going to use the default
rosters but custom rosters with custom
players make for some very interesting
possibilities before getting into the
create challenge tool we lock in our
team's uniforms and stadium this
challenge repeats a custom situation as
opposed to having the game progressed
normally
now we reach the main setup page the
left side shows your custom game
situations let's jump right in and set
up the situation we go with 10 attempts
is the length of this situation
ninth-inning down by one miggy up to bat
runners on using an auto hit we move the
ribbon and lock in McGee's towering
Drive it is possible to have multiple
situations play in sequence but for this
challenge we only need the one so let's
move on the right side is where you set
up your global set of goals
disqualifiers and custom challenge
settings by the end of this challenge in
order to succeed we want you to rob the
home run three times so we'll set three
put outs as the goal since it's at the
top of the list it also acts as the rank
stat in the dedicated leaderboard in
this challenge there are no
disqualifiers which are stats that would
result in instant failure also no custom
settings or sliders which would lock
specific options to this challenge step
two of creating a challenge is
determining what amount of risk and
reward you want to add to your challenge
it also explains how you as the
challenge creator standard stubbs every
time someone attempts your challenge in
the third and final step we name
described and tagged our challenge then
we must prove ourselves by succeeding at
the challenge we've just created this is
the final requirement before publishing
our challenge to the public and telling
all our friends to play it that's it for
this preview of community challenges so
go pre-order your copy of MLB 14 the
show start thinking about which
challenges you're going to take you to
the top of the featured list thanks for
watching
today's basil
you